I'm Nathan only about his Giles wired
and the gadget lab team is here at
digital experience a big exhibit where a
lot of companies come out to show off
their new you know their new gadgets the
new software the night before the CES
show floor officially opens now there's
a lot of stuff here that's not even
worth paying attention to a lot of noise
but there are a few things that caught
our eye for me if the huawei ascend mate
now this is a 6.1 inch android
smartphone that's coming out soon in
china but may or may not come out in the
US will see if carriers are convinced to
put on the store shelves but it sucks a
massive phone that wall way actually
Adam ate this make the keyboard smaller
so you can use it with one hand and you
can tap this little button to switch
which side of the screen shows up on its
kind of nutty but this is supposed to be
the largest phone out there in the
entire world biggest screen on a phone
it's basically a small tablet so there
it is found this interesting pillow here
that happens to be a Kickstarter project
and basically it connects two songs that
are playing on your iOS device via
bluetooth and it massages you to the
beats of that song so for example if
it's playing condom style it massages
you to those beats and it's kind of
weird but you know feels pretty good my
background is in engineering and
robotics so I'm a huge fan of the Lego
Mindstorms platform which makes
programming and getting into robotics as
easy snapping these pieces together for
the first time since 2006 Lego upgraded
their system and this is the new ev3
platform it's got a faster better
processor it's got additional sensors
and it's got more pieces that you can
put together to make more creations this
one is a snake and has a uses an IR
sensor to strike when things cross its
path
one last thing this year is a new
microphone from blue Mike's it's called
Nessie now you might be wondering why
it's called Nessie because it looks like
the Loch Ness monster yeah little corny
but anyways mu mike's makes high-end
mics for jay-z little Wayne a lot of
singers but this one plug in your laptop
via USB that's all we got from digital
experience but stay tuned to wire calm a
lot more from CES